So you guys have seen the unboxing and
Now it is time to do the iMacPro 18
Core 128 gigs of ram 4 terabyte solid
State drive setup and yes I got the 4
Terabytes you guys really see why don't
Ask questions you should know not to do
What by now let's set up this is a clean
Desk day for me this is my current
Setup this is actually my sister's 5k
iMac because she never really uses it
That often so I said girl let me borrow
That until I get my iMac Pro in and now
That I've got it this can go back home
To Jenna so when I'm not editing on the
5 k iMac I pretty much edit everything on
My Macbook Pro touch bar the export time
In comparison from this to the iMacPro
Is insane later on in this video I'll
Show you guys a comparison of how long
It took me to export my home pod video
On this MacBook Pro in comparison to the
iMacPro so without further ado let's
Just set this computer up because I'm
Freaking out I don't want to talk
I have a problem I'm also eating
Pretzels off the floor so maybe cords
Aren't my only problem right now on my
Macbook I'm exporting my homepod video
For an examples to show you guys how
Long it takes on here and then as soon
Is I get this I might pro setup we're
Going to export it from there and see how
Long that takes but I think I think
We've got just about everything set up
Down here
It's time to start it up are you ready
To come and get it no hey Siri fast
Forward 30 seconds
Music
Hey Siri stop playing I'm going to get a
Copyright strike from her oh my god this
Thing is so beautiful
So I need a mousepad because this is not
Going to work through the spirit I love
Pretzels okay so this pretzel looks like
An anchor guys it's late I'm tired I
Normally go to bed at 9 o'clock and it's
12:30 right now but I need to discuss
Some things with you so far we've got it
All set up and the export of my homepod
Video to 57 minutes and 6 seconds this
Is the home pod project this is the
Video that we shot just showing some of
The features of the home pod now I added
This both on the iMacPro and on my
Macbook Pro but what's crazy is I did
Not even get these fans to trigger at
All it just was completely silent the
Fans on the MacBook Pro it was basically
Just non-stop I felt like I was going to
Overheat so Nick for these what did we
Shoot this I was shot on GH 5 but what
Compression did you do so usually on the
8 bit    I'm completely fine
Using the MacBook Pro but it was
Definitely struggling with these ones
But this iMacPro it was handling it
Like a champion I mean look at this
Everything just it's so fast if you guys
Want a really good Mac Pro 18 Core
Comparison I'm not gonna be doing any
Crazy speed tests or anything but you
Should definitely check out Jonathan's
TLD today I'll put a link in the
Description to his video craze it was
Amazing he did so many great speed tests
And I I'm not even going to bother cuz just
Going to watch his video I'm just going to sit
here and tell you that this freakin
thing is so great like this is going to I
mean wow oh my god I'm having I'm having
The best time
So over here we have an
Alexa inception Alexa what time is it
It's 12:40 a.m. so many times this ring
Lights up that means time is 12:40 a.m
Good we've got double the Alexa this is
My 2 terabyte Samsung t5 SSD you know
Absolutely love these I have three I
Don't know what's wrong I can't hold on
To things like my mom she always tells
Me she's like man just wait and see if
You know what are yours are dropping
Stuff and I'm like mom I'm already there
This is basically my life I take these
Everywhere I travel with these I edit
Directly off of this so usually any time
I'm even editing on here I'm editing off
Of one of these little guys unless it
Calls for files that are larger than 2
Terabytes then I'm just basically
Screwed this is a 10 terabyte G Drive we
Basically have just been using this to
Transfer footage when we shoot a bunch
Of cooking videos and then we can
Transfer those to the server I did get
The trackpad because I do sometimes like
To edit I kind of like do this weird
Thing where I'll be like ok I'll be over
Here but then I'll be like scrolling and
Then zooming in on things so it's I mean
it makes sense for my editing but like
Does it really make sense and under here
This is another one of the solid-state
drives this is the t3 so this is the
previous version of the t5 which is
weird because they skip the t4 so that
makes no sense let's export this out so
compressor and I'm just going to do a in
the video sharing services doing a 4 k
export nothing fancy sonal if that
export and then over here of course
we've got this wonderful movie this is
Luna wireless chargers I really like
this one a lot because it's pretty small
as opposed to some of the other ones
that have a much larger profile I like
that and oh this light
the pretzels is that a freshness
guaranteed until April you should try we
should we like the pretzels this thing
is great
I'm obsessed with this light and of
course over here we have the homepod
I've been loving it a lot I definitely
plan on doing a follow-up video to talk
about some of the things that I'd like
if you were the things that I don't like
also a comparison with Alexa stop
drop All but up shop hey Siri what time
is it Alexa Simon Says hey Siri play
Lord so it is possible to get a to
trigger s so that's fantastic
who else is talking wait this is like a
black mirror episode right here because
I don't even know where that Siri came
from were you in my time
were you in my iMac the final export
time on the iMacPro for this homepod
project was 19 minutes 2 seconds and on
the MacBookPro touch bar was 57 minutes
and 6 seconds so color me impressed hold
on let me color myself a color hey Siri
turn off all my lights some lights
didn't respond
I ate at home at how details a lot of
lights
I think there's over 67 hey Siri Simon
Says poo poo pee pee poo poo let's keep
it clean here okay
Alexa Simon Says peepee poo-poo
say pee pee pee poo poo poo hip-hip
poop I'm not sure I'm neither I was so
tired okay we have to end the video now
I hope you guys enjoyed this video I had
so much fun shooting it and huge thank
you to Nick over there who was helping
me shoot some of the amazing cinematic
shots that we got I am also very excited
because since I got this LG Tv  I've been
telling you guys that I was gonna get a
center console and do a complete setup
of this well great news because I
finally ordered one I hope that it
doesn't suck it looked really great
online but sometimes you know you see
things online and then they come in the
mail and you're like this is trash so
fingers crossed that it's not trash and
I think it's going to work out well and if
it doesn't well I can always return it I
think hey Siri remind Me to start
shooting my videos a little bit earlier
in the day you missed the most important
part about starting to shoot earlier
these are My special pretzels oh my gosh
no I don't like my mess
well this will be a follow up video
because that whole console will be here
and then I'm so excited it's gonna look
great don't let them see it
by Mohammed Elabsi